I don't have Heroes Heroes is a big word
there are people that I look up to and
I've learned a lot from and Matt Ridley
has got to be near the top of that list
and most recently Matt wrote a great
book called How Innovation Works which
it'll be out by the time this podcast is
out there this has been your most
impactful book for me since Gino it was
very revealing if you're an entrepreneur
in Silicon Valley Shanghai or Bangalore
and you're thinking about creating
products whether it's social media
launching Rockets building airplanes or
genetic engineering you need to read
this book because it will give you a
better view of the history of innovation
as well as the future of innovation than
any other book that I know of that
context will be incredibly important
when you're trying to figure out things
like do I file patents how important is
the role of science how important is the
role of government how long will it take
for my Innovation to be adopted how much
can I expect to sink into legal battles
versus explaining things to people
versus building the product there's
conversation that goes on over and over
about almost everything in history which
is is history the product of a few great
men and women a few Great
accomplishments a few Great Moments a
few great battles a few great inventions
that happen to come along or is it an
inevitable inexorable and evolved
process you conclusively lay out lots of
evidence that Innovation is an
evolutionary process rather than
invention process and actually you call
it Innovation rather than invention that
seems a deliberate Choice tell me about
that choice I try and draw a distinction
between invention and Innovation it's
not a distinction that is cast in Iron
but I think this is the best way to
think about it invention is the coming
out with a prototype of a new device or
a new social practice Innovation is the
business of turning a new device into
something practical affordable and
reliable that people want to use and
acquire it's the process of driving down
the price it's process of driving up the
reliability and the efficiency of the
device and it's the process of
persuading other people to adopt it too
it's Thomas Edison captures this point
very well I don't think he used the word
Innovation much he used the word
invention but he is mainly an innovator
because he's not necessarily coming up
with original ideas he's taking other
people's ideas and turning them into
practical propositions it was he who
said that this is a process of 1%
inspiration and 99% perspiration what
I'm trying to do in this book is rescue
the perspiratory from
obscurity and slightly relegate the
inspirators who always think they
deserve the most credit and who
sometimes complain about not getting
enough reward because it's their
original idea I like to tell the story
which Charles towns used to tell the
inventor of the laser of a rabbit and a
beaver looking at the Hoover Dam and the
Beaver is saying to the rabbit no I
didn't build it but it's based on an
idea of
mine that is how inventors quite often
think about Innovation come on I had the
idea it's a huge amount of work and
talent to turn an idea into something
practical this is something that you
learn in Silicon valy very early on that
ideas are a dime a dozen every idea has
been floating around even a lot of the
old ideas that failed weren't
necessarily bad ideas they were just the
wrong time frankly if you're an
entrepreneur self- style inventor or
this is probably the cheapest fastest
education you can get on the history of
future of Innovations I highly recommend
it I'm going to leave with a quote that
I liked from the book that summarizes
what Innovation is where it's fostered
and it has a very optimistic and a
correct view of how it operates that
quote is innovation is the child of
freedom because it is a free and
creative attempt to satisfy freely
expressed human desires that's a
powerful quote from me it tells me that
Innovation requires Freedom it's
creative and we satisfying what people
want to do as opposed to what they're
told or forced to do I also read his
book the rational Optimist which helped
me realize that it was rational to be
optimistic because of the technological
advancement the scientific advancement
that we've had as human species since we
first came across fire the stone Axe and
basic tools let's do this last tweet you
said don't partner with cynics and
pessimists their beliefs are
self-fulfilling yeah essentially to
create things you have to be a rational
Optimist rational in the sense that you
have to see the world for what it really
is and yet you have to be optimistic
about your own capabilities and your
capability to get things done we all
know people who are consistently
pessimistic who will shoot down
everything everyone in their life has
like The Helpful critical guy right he
thinks he's being helpful but he's
actually being critical and he's a
downer on everything that person will
not only never do anything great in
their lives they'll prevent other people
around them for doing something great
they think their job is to shoot holes
in things and it's okay to shoot holes
in things as long as you come with a
solution there's also the classic like
military line either lead follow or get
out of the way and these people want a
fourth option where they don't want to
lead they don't want to follow but they
don't want to get out of the way they
want to tell you why the thing's not
going to work and all the really
successful people I know have a very
strong action bias they just do things
the easiest way to figure out if
something's viable or not is by doing it
at least do the first step and the
second step and the third and then
decide so if you want to be successful
in life creating wealth or having good
relationships or being fit or even being
happy you need to have an action bias
towards getting what you want and you
have to be optimistic about it not
irrationally there's nothing worse than
someone who's just like fool hearty and
chasing it's not work that's why I say
rational Optimist but you have to be
rational know all the pitfalls know the
downsides but still keep your chin up I
mean you've got one life on this planet
why not try to build something big this
is the beauty of Elon Musk and why I
think he inspires so many people it's
just because he takes on really really
big audacious tasks and he provides an
example for people to think big and it
takes a lot of work to build even small
things I don't think the corner grocery
store owner is working any less hard
than Elon Musk or pouring any less sweat
and toil into it maybe even more but for
whatever reason you know education
circumstance they didn't get the chance
to think as big so the outcome's not as
big so it's just better to think big
obviously rationally with your means to
stay optimistic the cynics and the
pessimists what they're really saying
and fortunate but they're saying I've
given up I don't think I can do anything
and so the world to me just looks like a
world where nobody can do anything and
so why should you go do something
because if you fail then I'm right which
is great but if you succeed then you
just make me look bad I normally don't
travel for conferences but when I got
the opportunity to speak with Nim I I
had to come down um from San Francisco
to me he is one of the very very very
few living natural philosophers which is
someone who practices science does real
work in science but outside of a
scientific institution outside of the
credential system and I think his work
is the kind of work that will last for a
thousand years I I don't say that
lightly but but I I think I think people
will be reading you know there there
there are books that massim has written
and I won't insult him by calling him Dr
TB is that okay just call you it is Sal
typically so I want you by calling you
Dr T but Nim has written books that I
think people will be reading a years
from now his new book skin of the game
is is fantastic it's part five in his
incerto series which includes uh full by
Randomness Black Swan antifragile the
better procrustes um it's it's written
in a very Timeless way the concepts are
very simple there's not a lot of math to
it although there is a huge math backing
to the in cherto if you want to get into
it um and I would I would rather reread
his work than anything on the bestseller
list and I have uh many of his books
I've I've reread if you haven't read all
five of his books I wouldn't read
anything else this year I would
literally just absorb them and I don't
say that lightly that's true for me like
I'm going through skin the game he's got
to convince me to to read my books yeah
they're they're they're amazing the
first one was finished 20 years ago so
you got to understand that I'm well
there there is some redundancy in there
as as you you would you would expect and
I think the a common theme that Nim
pointed out to me when we talked earlier
running through the whole thing is this
concept of symmetry and asymmetry skin
in the game is about symmetry between uh
your consequences of your actions and
learning and feedback loops and
asymmetry is about extreme outcomes so
uh you know Black Swan and and uh those
kinds of principles why don't you
explain Symmetry and asymmetry in in
okay so now you don't understand random
events you can't predict what can happen
but you can pretty much tell how the
random event would hit you no you know
whether you're going to make from it
lose from it make a lot lose a lot okay
so you try to position yourself in a way
to benefit more than you would lose from
a random event
okay or to lose less than your neighbor
from random event that's that's the idea
of a symmetry it's pretty much like an
option what I call an option an option
you make more on the upside than you
would on the
downside and if you in or in general
make more from a random event then you
lose from it then you're going to do
very well in the long run provided you
make sure you're going to survive that's
the Symmetry that's present and
contracts and option stuff like that
that asymmetry becomes bad when you make
the upside like what
ruin and transfer the downside to
someone else and and the easiest thing
to transfer to person to transfer to the
taxpayer Anonymous taxpayer you see so
that is an asymmetry okay a bad
asymmetry but tinkering uh trial and
error it is has a really a positive
asymmetry so simple you know example I
give I would give is if we wanted what's
your favorite
dish uh it's pizza but I shouldn't be
eating it Pizza what but I shouldn't be
eating it okay so Pizza okay so let's
say we decide to make the best pizza
that would call it the Santa Monica
Flying Pizza all right here so you you
you you you rent a bus you go to the
local University and bring every chemist
run up every chemist you can find okay
and then and you take another bus and
run up every overweight person you can
find an LA who's well-dressed this is my
metric when you go to a restaurant is
the look at for overweight people who
are well-dressed okay that's that's
that's sort of like uh you know my my my
thing so and then so we have two crowds
now
okay so if we ask a chemist that's a top
down
okay to uh uh invent that pizza you ask
chemist you about what 150 chemists all
looking boring and poorly fed and and
visibly not well-dressed
and and then you ask the well-dressed
people whatever overweight you tell them
listen uh let's make the best pizza so
the way you do it is you take an
existing recipe and you start adding
ingredients to it no and you taste if
it's good you ratch it
up okay so you have the upside if it's
good you discover something that really
has good taste you go up or you rash it
up in other words you lock up your gain
okay no if it's bad do you give it to a
chemist I have very little to lose all
right so that is trial and error with a
lot of trial and error
and you can I showed an antifragile and
that's the main argument that trial and
error will always outperform
design simply because of that property
that we're vastly more
intelligent we have an IQ of a thousand
when we do trial and
error I was very pleasantly surprised a
couple of years back that I reopened an
old book which I had read or I thought
I'd read about a decade ago called the
beginning of infinity by David Deutsch
sometimes you read a book and it makes a
difference right away sometimes you read
a book and you don't understand it then
you read it later at the right time and
it makes a difference this time when I
reopened this book and I went through it
much more carefully than I had in the
past meticulously rather than reading it
to read it and to say I was done reading
it I read it to understand the concepts
and the topics and stopped at every
point where something was new it
completely started reforming my
worldview it changed the way I think and
I would credit this book as being
probably the only book in the last
decade except maybe a few of Nasim
taleb's works and maybe one or two other
scattered books that I feel made me
smarter they literally expanded the way
that I think they expanded not just the
repertoire of my knowledge but the
repertoire of my reasoning people throw
around words like mental models a lot
and I find most mental models not worth
reading or thinking about or listening
to because I find them trivial however
the mental models that came out of the
beginning of infinity are
transformational because they very
convincingly completely changed the way
that you look at what is true and what
is not Carl popper laid out the theory
of what is scientific and what is not
what is a good explanation what is not
and what deuts does is he expands on
that dramatically in the beginning of
Infinity but even that is to do it a
disservice the wide- ranging nature of
what he covers in the beginning of
infinity is incredible he goes from the
theory of knowledge which goes by the
fancy word epistemology all the way to
quantum mechanics and physics and
Multiverse Theory
to infinity and Mathematics to the reach
of what is noble and what is not Noble
Universal explanations the theory of
computation what is beauty what systems
of politics works better how to raise
your children these are all encompassing
long range philosophical ideas
Reflections let me now share with you
two of my favorite quotes from Navarra
vant on this topic of reading the first
one is read what you love until you love
to read and the second quote is is read
enough and you become a koser then you
naturally gravitate more towards Theory
Concepts and
non-fiction now I'll leave you with an
insightful observation from the
philosopher John Stewart Mill on why
most people will prefer to be pessimist
rather than optimists I've observed that
not the man who hopes when others
despair but the man who despairs when
others hope is admired by a large class
of persons as a sage so that's all for
today's nuggets and if you also want to
get the best nuggets from books I
recommend you to check out short form
which is a platform that I personally
love using because I can learn from many
books in a super efficient way short
form is not a sponsoring this video but
I do have an affiliate link which is
short for.com picking nuggets you can
also find it below in the description
and you can use it to get a 5-day free
trial and a 20% discount on the annual
subscription